trouver sa place sur le marché du
travail
lorsqu'on est une personne porteuse de
handicap n'est pas une mince affaire
depuis deux ans arienzo qui est porteur
d'une déficience mentale travail avec
unique communal d'entretien des espaces
verts
il est en contrat d'apprentissage il
suit en alternance des cours au cfa et
prépare son ca paix d'agent d'entretien
des espaces verts
ophélie porteuses de handicap mental est
également en contrat d'apprentissage
elle prépare son ca paix d'agent
polyvalent en restauration
pour ces étudiants se trouvaient dans un
parcours de professionnalisation
classique et fasse un peu leur handicap
alors qu'obama fasse ça je me sens mieux
parce que je suis dans mon élément et
j'aime dette comme tout le monde
passez un moment que mon ordi tu as tu
encore là bas comme tout le monde sait
bien ce dispositif qui est une première
à la réunion tronche avec le parcours
classique d'une personne handicapée pour
la majorité d'entre eux ils suivent
d'habitude un parcours en institution
spécialisée
et lorsqu'il s'agit de travailler il
s'oriente le plus souvent faire un
établissement de service d'aidé par le
travail au complexe edmond albius de la
lève pas l'équipe professionnelle a mis
en place une démarche qui ne passe pas
par l'institution il propose aux
personnes handicapées une insertion
professionnelle identique aux personnes
ordinaires
depuis 2005 nous conduisons une démarche
dite de désinstitutionnalisation et nous
avions l'opportunité de créer un
institut médico-pédagogique à
l'intérieur de vos murs nous avons fait
un autre choix ce choix nous a conduits
à développer du partenariat avec l'école
l'école primaire dans un premier temps
ensuite de collège et ensuite de lisser
à l'arrivée à l'inde et à la fin de
l'adolescence au début du monde adulte
il faut effectivement trouver des
solutions pour son avenir et donc par
conséquent la voie de l'apprentissage
est apparu tout à fait naturel et un
certain nombre de partenaires ont
souhaité nous accompagner dans cette
voie douze jeunes porteurs de
déficiences mentales sont accompagnés
dans cette démarche d'inclusion or de
l'institution pour eux être logés à la
même enseigne
comme tout un chacun c'est un plus pour
leur intégration sociale c'est plus
familiarisés avec les apps
et je me sens plus trop timide quand je
parle avec quelques heures quand je
finis mon travail je rentre à la maison
je juge thaung avril et comme les
mauvais camarade je suis grâce à la
maison je ne saura pas plus je me repose
pour le lendemain
pour mener à bien ce projet d'insertion
dans le milieu ordinaire il a fallu
accompagner aussi bien les jeunes que
les professionnels qui n'étaient pas
habitués à appréhender le handicap pour
mes débuts quand marie vialle à venir
ici mais pour moi ils démarrent éviter
quelques uns et des biens des biens la
façon dans la vie physique mais en fin
de compte et c'était pas le physique
enfin considérer moral
il ya des choses qui ont mis des billes
et escautpont pas donc mais ça va
doucement mais mettez un mois elle par
exemple manier le robot est donc mais
quelle langue il faut mettre paul
choquel l'amf m aux carottes
il fait son travail il écoutait la reine
problème ici au niveau handicap et en
fin de compte - lluis gêne pas et me
gêne pas son handicap est donc au niveau
le travail son travail des fois le foehn
tir au palais la lydec nous pas de
problème au contraire si la commune y
voit les comme ça il faut une bonne
maman
moussa des fois on en a qui arrivent
mais y écoute pas qu'on continue berrier
good men on a des gens qui arrivent aux
autres plié et que le chef salaires et
voilà il arrive des ti paul getty
premier problème mais comme les non ça
va il ya fait travailler bonnement mal
comme ça
l'appréhension de travailler avec des
personnes porteuses de déficience
mentale s'est également produite au
niveau des centres de formation si
aujourd'hui chaque étudiant a trouvé sa
place au départ rien n'était acquis moi
personnellement en tant qu'enseignant la
cuisine d'encore il était un petit peu
je vais dit ascétique parapente à cela
parce que comme c'est une première fois
donc prenez pas trop
aussi bien en enseignement général donc
du coup après on s'est plus souvent
habitué
donc on s'est habitué on s'est mis dans
le vin la première expérience je dirais
que c'est devenu la bonne parce qu'en
fait on s'est adapté un petit peu avec
le travail avec ces gens là ont
s'adapter à eux ils sont adaptés à nous
on a eu les accompagnateurs donc à peu
au fil du temps ces gens là ils sont mis
en confiance
et du coup on les retrouve sur le
travail donc ils ont beaucoup plus
d'assurance aujourd'hui quand les va
travailler et peuvent travailler en
toute autonomie pour une première pour
moi personnellement ça s'est transformé
en un coup de maître
après on va voir ce que ça va donner à
l'examen ceci ne veut pas dire non plus
qu à l'examen du premier coup ils vont
avoir leur exemple il va avoir le
diplôme comme tous les autres pour
accompagner ces deux jeunes tout au long
du parcours vers l'obtention de leur
diplôme
ils sont suivis par une éducatrice
spécialisée de la nef pas elles veillent
aux besoins liés à leur handicap
il ya des difficultés propres au
handicap il y a des besoins de
compensation en fait déjà ça passe par
une certaine observation une interaction
active entre les différents partenaires
qui sont sur le projet du chaque jeune
ce qui me permet après moi d'analyser
d'évaluer les besoins de chacun et de
travailler avec eux sur les réponses à
apporter les solutions apportées à leurs
difficultés
les difficultés ophélie et oriengo
entendent bien les dépasser
j'ai une formatrice à mes côtés aussi
donc elle m'aide beaucoup
le québécois lee john est plus facile
des points le coup et non l'handicaper
m'empêchera pas de conduire dans mon
métier comme des étudiants tous qu'il ya
d'ordinaire ils travaillent à
l'obtention de leur diplôme à la fin de
cette année scolaire
j'espère que je fais la voix aussi
nouveau faux d'arreau refaire encore un
nom ont gagné mais je crois peut-être
que je veux gagner je gagne c'est bien